bien estamos en el problema número 6
guau no esto está bastante grueso creo
que no es lo que queremos digo no se ve
mal este 6 pero creo que exagera está
demasiado grueso lo que pasa es que
reinicie mi computadora y creo que se
reinicio todo pero ya está aquí el
problema número 6 muy bien dice sí m y
camps son constantes positivas cuanto
vale y tenemos una expresión bastante
pero bastante
la voy a apuntar bastante amena pero a
la vez bastante llamativa 10 por m al
cuadrado por cam elevado a la menos 1
esto es igual a 100 m haciendo m y bueno
lo que me pregunta este problema es
cuánto vale m a la menos 1 en términos
de k n al menos 1 en función de cada en
función
de acá y tengo esta expresión de aquí
así que tomemos esa misma expresión la
voy a apuntar aquí 10 m cuadrada acá a
la menos 1 esto es igual a 100 m y se ve
muy rimbombante por aquí se ve muy
llamativa sin embargo aun creo que lo
primero que podemos hacer es expresar
este término bueno de hecho lo primero
que podemos hacer es dividir entre 10
voy a dividir entre 10 esta parte lo voy
a quitar y esto me va a quedar 10 de tal
manera que obtengo m cuadrada por acá a
la menos 1 esto es igual a 10 m perfecto
hasta aquí y ahora lo que se me ocurre
hacer es dividir todo entre m todavía
puedo dividir todo entre m de tal manera
que esté cuadrado se va a ir y está m se
va a ir y me queda que m por acá a la
menos uno
esto es igual a 10
quiero que te des cuenta de algo aquí lo
que nos hace ruido es este acá al menos
uno sin embargo recuerda que por las
leyes de los exponentes cuando tengo una
variable elevada a una potencia negativa
esto es exactamente lo mismo que pasar a
esa variable dividiendo con su
respectiva potencia positiva es decir es
lo mismo que m entre camps cala menos 1
es lo mismo que uno entre camps por m me
queda en meter cam y esto es igual a 10
y ya casi terminó ahora si multiplicó a
ambos lados de esta ecuación por camps
me va a quedar que m es igual a 10 cam
hasta aquí creo que vamos perfecto sin
embargo date cuenta que no me preguntan
el valor de m lo que me preguntan es el
valor de m elevado a la menos 1 pero m
elevado a la menos uno antes de apuntar
lo aquí m elevado a la menos 1 es
exactamente lo mismo justo por lo que
acabamos de ver que
1 / m es decir el inverso multiplicativo
de m y si yo lo que quiero es 1 entre m
pues qué te parece si saco el inverso de
ambos lados de esta ecuación me va a
quedar que 1 / m es exactamente lo mismo
que 1 entre 10 k o dicho de otra manera
m a la menos uno es lo mismo que 1 entre
10 acá y ya está
tengo expresado a m elevado a la menos 1
como una función de camps y esto de
hecho nos dicen que es el inciso de
perfecto ya está aquí la respuesta muy
bien vamos a hacer ahora el problema
número 7 el problema número 7 que dice
lo siguiente
bien y déjame tomar otro color voy a
tomar el color malva este color que
tengo aquí muy bien
y el problema siguiente dice eloísa y
alejandra dejan la casa de un amigo en
común al mismo tiempo y caminan durante
cuatro horas entonces van a caminar
durante cuatro horas a caminar durante
cuatro horas cuatro horas ok
eloísa camina en dirección este a una
velocidad promedio de 4 kilómetros por
hora y se me ocurre que voy a hacer aquí
la casa del amigo en común va a ser esta
de aquí y esta es su casa
como una casa de un pitufo o algo así
esta es la casa del amigo en común y
bueno aquí tiene un arbolito aquí tiene
un arbolito ok muy bien y entonces
eloísa va a caminar hacia el este hacia
el este para acá no esperas ver de hecho
este es el oeste hacia el este es decir
hacia acá va a caminar el lobbista
durante cuatro horas con una velocidad
promedio de 4 kilómetros por hora de 4
kilómetros por hora
exacto muy bien y va a caminar durante
cuatro horas mientras que por su parte
alejandra va a caminar hacia el norte
déjame cambiar de color al color de
alejandra muy bien alejandra va a
caminar hacia el norte es decir para acá
va a caminar también durante cuatro
horas pero a una velocidad promedio de
tres kilómetros por hora de tres
kilómetros por hora muy bien
cuál es la distancia mínima que la
separa una vez transcurridas las cuatro
horas y bueno si después de cuatro horas
alejandra se encuentra aquí y si después
de cuatro horas
eloísa se encuentra aquí estás de
acuerdo que la distancia mínima entre
esos dos puntos pues es una línea recta
es decir esencialmente lo que me piden
es la distancia de esta recta de esta
recta que tengo aquí muy bien y si te
das cuenta que puedes tener un poco de
intuición de que este problema se basa
en un triángulo rectángulo mira bien
tengo aquí un triángulo rectángulo este
ángulo de 90 grados este es un ángulo
recto y entonces puedo calcular esta
distancia como pues sería muy bueno
saber cuánta distancia recorrió la visa
en loíza recurrió a qué distancia bueno
si ella fue a una velocidad de 4
kilómetros por hora durante 4 horas esto
quiere decir que en cada hora recorrió 4
kilómetros después de 4 horas pues se ha
recorrido 16 km esta distancia es de 16
kilómetros muy bien en cuatro horas ella
va a recorrer 16 kilómetros
por su parte aquí tengo una velocidad de
3 kilómetros por hora tengo una
velocidad de 3 kilómetros por hora
pero alejandra camino 4 horas y entonces
4 por 3 es 12 12 kilómetros fue lo que
recorrió alejandra 3 kilómetros por cada
una de las horas y si yo quiero sacar
esta distancia esta distancia que le voy
a llamar x entonces puedo aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras y el teorema de
pitágoras dice que la hipotenusa elevada
al cuadrado es decir x elevado al
cuadrado
es exactamente lo mismo que uno de los
catetos elevado al cuadrado es decir 12
elevado al cuadrado 12 elevado al
cuadrado más el otro cateto elevado al
cuadrado es decir 16 elevado al cuadrado
más 16 elevado al cuadrado y nuestro
resultado nos va a dar en kilómetros y
cuando esto x cuadrado es igual a 12 al
cuadrado 12 al cuadrado es 144 144 más
16 al cuadrado 16 por 16 cuánto es 16
por 16 a 6 por 6 36 llevamos 3 a 6 por
unas 6 y 3 son 9 después aquí 16 y 10 y
después voy a sumar esto y me va a
quedar 65 2 256 más 256 y si yo quiero
sumar esto que me va a dar que x
cuadrada es decir la distancia que yo
quiero elevada al cuadrado es
exactamente igual a 64 es 10
64 es 10 otra vez que llevamos una 2 y
una que llevamos son 3 y una son 4 x
cuadrada es igual a 400 o dicho de otra
manera x es la raíz cuadrada de 400 la
raíz cuadrada positiva porque estamos
hablando de una distancia y por lo tanto
x es igual a 20 x es igual a 20 que es
justo lo que yo quería que por cierto es
el insisto en la distancia que las
separan en línea recta a alejandra de
luisa después de 4 horas de trayecto
bueno pues es el inciso de 20 km 20
kilómetros muy bien un problema 7 vamos
al problema número 8 y estoy usando un
libro de ejercicios viejo que usaba mi
sobrina cuando iba a la secundaria y
ahora ella va terminando la preparatoria
guau cómo ha pasado el tiempo bueno lo
que pasa es que ella tenía subrayados
algunos problemas que eran los que tenía
que resolver y esto no causa un poco de
dificultad para leerlo
y también está genial porque ella tiene
circular la respuesta así que no es que
estemos haciendo trampa
simplemente corroboramos que su
respuesta o la mía estén bien es como
una segunda forma de comprobar que vamos
bien
en fin regresemos a los problemas que
estamos resolviendo así que vayamos al
problema número 8 y bueno no es por
presumir pero hasta ahorita no ha tenido
ningún problema mal
en fin regresemos al problema número 8
la figura siguiente bueno de hecho ella
es la razón por la cual empecé a hacer
estos vídeos por intentar ayudarle en
sus notas empezó el proyecto de khan
academy yo le explicaba un tema en estos
vídeos que por cierto estamos en el
problema número 8 les explicaba un tema
en estos vídeos y vio mejoría en sus
notas así que con esto empecé a hacer un
montón de vídeos y lo curioso es que un
montón de gente empezó a verlos y muchos
de ellos empezaron a ver mejorías en sus
notas en fin así que veamos si no se
equivocan en el problema número 8 que
tiene la gráfica así
este es mi eje y este es mi bien por
aquí tengo a mi eje x por aquí tengo al
que hace x bien y después dice la
gráfica siguiente muestra la
representación de una función cuadrática
tengo la función cuadrática dibujada
aquí es decir de una parábola cuyo punto
mínimo está en el punto 1-1 así que si
camino 1 para acá y 1 para acá aquí
tengo el punto mínimo es más déjeme
cambiar de color
vamos a utilizar el color de las
parábolas se me ocurre utilizar este
color este de aquí este es un punto
mínimo de mi parábola muy bien es el
punto 11 1,1
ahora sí nosotros sabemos qué se debe
efe db es igual a efe de 3 a efe de 3 y
esto por cierto es igual a 5 lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale ve cuánto vale
b este es el eje de las equis este es el
eje de las 10 ésta no parece x ahora ya
parece un poco más una equis muy bien y
tengo que efe de ven igual a efe de tres
es igual a 5 donde está el 3 bueno el 3
está
23 aquí tengo el 3 y ft 35 es decir que
si nosotros subimos aquí uno dos tres
cuatro cinco por aquí tendríamos a esta
parábola la tendríamos pasando por este
punto por este punto muy bien y ahora
voy a intentar hacer lo mejor posible
una parábola por aquí de tal manera que
me conecte a este punto con este otro
punto lo mejor posible ok y bueno es
simétrica con respecto a este punto al
punto mínimo va a ser algo muy parecido
a esto va a subir también por aquí bien
aquí tengo a mi parábola ahora me dicen
que f de 3 es igual a 5 que es este
punto de aquí aquí estoy en el punto 3 5
sin embargo hay otro punto llamado bm
que también cumple que efe db es igual a
5 y esto tiene mucha lógica porque si
está
la bola es simétrica bajo esta línea que
estoy dibujando es decir la línea que
pasa por el punto mínimo bajo este mismo
punto entonces aquí tenemos un valor de
x para el cual fx es igual a 5 del otro
lado también tenemos que tener un valor
de x que f de x-men de 5 y de hecho pues
estar más o menos por aquí más o menos
porque bueno el dibujo no está exacto
ahora mi pregunta es qué punto es este
este punto tiene una coordenada en x 5 y
yo lo que quiero saber es qué coordenada
en x tiene y para resolver esto lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que lo que
voy a caminar de un lado es lo mismo que
voy a caminar del otro como esta
parábola es simétrica bajo este eje
entonces lo que yo caminé de aquí hasta
acá en x base es lo mismo que lo que
tengo que caminar de aquí hasta acá en x
es decir si de aquí acá yo recorrí de 1
a 3 es decir 2 unidades
entonces de aquí a acá tengo que
recorrer 2 unidades para llegar
a este valor de 5 porque estamos
hablando de una palabra asimétrica
aunque aquí no se vea muy simétrica que
digamos
y si yo recorro dos unidades pero ahora
la izquierda después en uno pues estaría
retrocediendo dos unidades 10 menos 1 es
decir que en el -1 en el -1 voy a tocar
también el punto 5 este punto sería el
punto menos 15 o dicho de otra manera el
valor de p que tanto estamos buscando es
igual a menos 12 unidades menos que 1 ya
está que por cierto es el inciso c así
que ya tengo esta respuesta de aquí y me
da tiempo de hacer un último problema de
manera muy rápida vámonos al problema
número 9 y para esto voy a cambiar de
color ahora me voy a tomar el color
segundo problema número 9 que dice lo
siguiente habla de viajes una familia de
cinco integrantes está planeando un
viaje de cuatro días en él
tengo cinco integrantes integrantes y
esto lo voy a multiplicar por cuatro
días en el campo por cuatro días porque
porque dice cada persona va a necesitar
una botella de agua para cada día del
viaje entonces esta es lo veo
multiplicar por una botella por cada día
una botella
ahora bien si las botellas están
empapadas en paquetes de tres cuántos
paquetes de botellas de agua son
necesarios llevar al viaje tengo cinco
integrantes iban a ir cuatro días y cada
día van a utilizar una botella de agua
es decir que en total voy a necesitar
cinco por cuatro por uno son veinte
botellas voy a estar 20 botellas ahora
el problema es que están empaquetadas de
tres en tres
entonces si yo llevo a seis paquetes
seis por tres es 18 y me faltarían dos
botellas entonces seis paquetes no es
necesario
necesitamos siete paquetes siete
paquetes para que alcance el agua para
todos para que todos tengan suficiente
agua durante estos cuatro días y ya está
tengo aquí la respuesta así que este
estaba bastante sencillo nada mal y el
siguiente problema lo voy a resolver en
el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima